these masters don't even realize they're
alive the toys are born into a system
where the very fact that they are alive
is kept in the closet
whatever that child wants that toy must
oblige is it even possible to kill a toy
there is one other way this whole Toy
Story could play out
a human burst toy total war
hello Internet
welcome to film theory last time we
discussed the horrific realities of
being a toy in the Toy Story universe
you have one purpose in life and god
forbid you strive for anything else and
that one purpose requires you to be
controlled by masters who don't even
know you're alive your very existence is
kept secret as a result you have
literally no say in all the awful things
that are gonna be done to you it's
thankless it's humiliating and there is
no escape even if you wanted to die you
can't unless of course you're willing to
burn or explode yourself it sucks for as
bright and fun as these movies are it is
undeniably the worst Pixar world be
trapped as a character in but that may
not be true for much longer you see
there's a storm coming if you go back
and look across the three Toy Story
movies as well as the trailer for number
four there's a disturbing trend that you
can see happening on screen war is on
the horizon a war between servant master
toy and human the toys are getting
closer and closer to fighting back
fighting back in a big way when they do
let's just say it's not gonna look too
good for us humans don't believe me
leave your childhoods at the door
because you're about to get drafted into
the great Toy Story war remember back in
the first movie when a toy getting
knocked out of the bedroom window was
the single worst thing that could
possibly happen to a toy
[Music]
[Applause]
but well fast-forward to the Toy Story 4
trailer and we now have toys leaping out
of windows left and right they're
traveling cross-country to save each
other and then wind up back with their
human overlords but the important thing
to note here is that they're exerting
what they want in the original Toy Story
our favorite characters were helpless
they were indoctrinated into this belief
that they had no control over their own
destinies that they were helpless in the
face of disasters they couldn't cross
out of Andy's room without his
permission
but Buzz's disappearance in the first
movie and the subsequent rescue mission
gave them the taste of freedom they saw
outside of their bubble they got a taste
of the outside world and it showed them
that they had more control and power
than they could have ever known so much
so that they could fight back against
the very humans they were built to
entertain so today I think I'm
over-exaggerating early on in the series
the toys sit around helplessly waiting
to be played with by their human masters
but as the film's go on not only did the
toys realize that they can simply play
with other toys and cut out the human
middleman but they can also start
enacting schemes to get exactly what
they want out of their human masters
even going so far as to manipulate Andy
with phone calls and post-it notes
hello I mean that is next-level
manipulation seriously just stop and
look at where the toys are now long gone
are the days when it literally took an
army to spy on Andy
[Music]
wait turn that thing back on
by the time Toy Story 3 rolls around the
toys can easily surveil Andi remotely
it's impossible as we see the potato
heads learning to use their unique
powers as toys to good use good
strategic use and the mr. and mrs. here
aren't the only ones doing this in the
first movie the closest to flight buzz
ever got was accidentally falling with
style now in the Toy Story 4 trailer we
see him able to launch himself and glide
at will and what's more not only are
they mastering their own abilities
they're also mastering human technology
in the original film these dum-dums
could barely manage to put batteries
into a walkie-talkie but by Toy Story 3
they're more tech-savvy than your
parents whose velocity are 2 3 7 oh
that's a dinosaur toy down the street
that's nothing let me just take care of
that the dinosaur that clip is important
because it shows not only that Andy's
toys have mastered things like online
communication and online gaming but also
that they're not the only toys doing it
that's way down street all the toys in
the neighborhood all the toys in the
world are getting smarter they're
getting savvy er so the toys are
asserting themselves they're learning
that's not that big of a deal though
since for now they're happy doing all
that in service of us humans the key
words there though are for now remember
the toy existence is a brutal cycle
they're created out of a kid's love and
imagination which is beautiful but child
loves his toy and a toy loves his child
but from that point forward the toys
existence is a constant stream of
mistreatment until they're eventually
forgotten about and thrown away by the
very person who brought them to life in
the first place it is thankless and it
is sad you can only put up with those
sorts of indignities for so long before
you expect something better
and now in Toy Story 4 you can start to
see the seeds of revolt being sown for
key doesn't want to be a toy Bo Peep is
actively pursuing an independent life
and trying to convince woody to do the
same they're both characters who
recognize the failure of the system they
exist in and are looking to break the
wheel I'm going to break the wheel um
maybe let's not use that clip anymore
but seriously there is descent rising up
among the toys and where there's descent
there's the spark of war don't take it
from me either
to understand something about the art of
war what causes it and who wins
I turn to r.j. Rummel the acclaimed
political scientist who literally wrote
the book on this stuff Rommel identified
six socio-political causes of
international conflict war and guess
what toy story solidly checks all six
boxes point number one significant
change in the balance of powers just so
happens that we just talked about this
one toys are figuring out how awesome
they are they're starting to take action
they're manipulating humans to do what
they want and mastering skills that give
them incredible advantages over their
puny human counterparts big ol check in
that box
point number two opposing interests and
capabilities let me ask you this is
there a disparity of interests between
humans and toys think about that for a
moment gel we thought their best human
owners grow up and lose interest in toys
at their worst they torture and mangle
toys into tiny pieces there is no way
for toys to win in this scenario humans
want to grow up and it's in a toys best
interests if they don't check next point
number three contact and salience what's
this mean well it basically just means
are the two groups aware of one another
in this case almost no humans know about
the sentient of toys despite almost
every household having them meaning that
toys who are very aware of their humans
have already fully infiltrated every
corner of human existence but still
possess the element of surprise it's
like six billion Trojan horses have
found their way into every home across
the entire world are the two groups in
contact with one another you
they are number four individual
perceptions and expectations now this
one has to do with whether the two
groups understand and empathize with
each other situations and feel the same
things if they do know war if they don't
the battle is on baby and in the case of
toy story well this one's just laughable
since toys are constantly heartbroken
when their child grows up well the child
has no perception of how their toy feels
they have no clue that they even have to
meet the expectations of the toy in the
first place meanwhile all the toy knows
is abandonment after a cycle or two of
that the toys start to catch on they
start to grow bitter they start to get
angry they start to become a lot like a
lot so something changed that day inside
Lockhart she replaced a lot saw wasn't a
villain he was just a revolutionary
ahead of his time point number five a
disrupted structure of expectations this
one is all about whether the status quo
has changed is one group starting to
expect better or at least different
treatment well the toys have started to
get more frequent tastes of freedom
they're starting to warm up to the
notion of self-determination and with it
the entire slave to children social
structure that's persisted up to this
point the movies is being threatened
even in characters like Woody who has
been one of the strictest loyalists to
the existing system if someone doesn't
want to abandon his kid whether it's
Andy or Bonnie it is woody and even
Woody's faith in this system is starting
to shake
woody are we going to buy but at the end
of the day the checkbox that truly
matters the most is the last one point
number six will - conflict do the toys
have it in them to actually do anything
about their situation would they really
attack the humans that they love so
dearly the answer is yeah toys already
have a track record of will to conflict
against humans who mistreat um not all
toys of course I don't like
confrontations and some when it seems
like toys are getting abused and
mistreated like in the case of Sid the
toys show that they are willing to push
back and as we've seen Thai population
at large is waking up to this idea that
they're being mistreated all the time
just physical mistreatment by crazed
kids who Frankenstein baby heads on
her legs but emotional mistreatment from
the supposedly good owners who grow up
and abandon them I'm not saying we're
here just yet in Toy Story 4 but
literally everything in the history of
the world shows that the relationship
between toys and humans is a powder keg
where every risk factor exists and also
CEO political signs point towards
violent conflict and that's the last
area that we have to carry out to its
logical conclusion here friends because
if toys are becoming assertive if
they're truly becoming masters of their
own fate and encouraging other toys to
do the same it means that over time the
balance of power is shifting from people
playing with toys toys playing with
people but we humans don't understand is
how much trouble we'd be in if our toys
truly revolted let's look at the
evidence for a start
toys are far smarter than humans who
needs all that childhood development
nonsense when you could be at full
strength from the get-go frytss buzz
isn't even alive for 10 minutes before
he's falling with style
he's multilingual with a flip of a
switch you know you amigo Oh a mini go
compare that to humans who need to be
alive for at least a year before they so
much as walk and who needs 600 to 750
classroom hours to learn Spanish as a
Second Language we can't overlook the
simple truth that toys as a population
have successfully kept the very fact
they're alive under wraps generation
after generation owner after owner it is
the best-kept secret ever and all the
toys every last one has been able to
maintain that ruse forever so toys are
smarter big deal but brains aren't
everything right I mean after all humans
are bigger and stronger than toys for
now at least there's one scene that I've
always wanted to talk about here on film
theory and today is finally the day the
tortilla scene with mr. Potato Head in
Toy Story 3 mr. Potato Head puts his
eyeballs into a plain non tight or TIA
and suddenly he has physical control
over said tortilla he becomes mr.
tortilla head in that one moment he's
effectively turned an inanimate object
into a sentient being instantaneously
consider the ramifications of this one
scene if toys can control non toy
objects so they've essentially invented
avatars
and ins for themselves made of any
object they can imagine or stick an ear
into I guess a tortilla eat so
threatening but stick those eyes onto a
tree
and who suddenly have a literal whomping
willow on your hands removable and
swappable body parts give toys what
almost amount to superpowers for
instance mrs. Potato heads I can
literally transmit images back to the
rest of her body from across town
meaning that any ear or eye left behind
can serve as its own immortal
surveillance equipment and the potato
heads with their tortillas and remote
surveillance demonstrates something else
that's even more threatening if they can
suddenly split their bodies into a small
handful of different pieces and operate
all of them independently well then why
can't they split them up into two dozen
different pieces or three dozen a
thousand a billion is the spark that
gives a toy life inherent in every atom
of its body wood crushing or
incinerating a toy do anything or would
that just create an army of many many
many millions of tiny mini toys I
brought it up last episode but toys are
already gonna be a really hard enemy to
kill since experiments prove that even a
fishing pole with legs can be alive but
if that's the case where is the end of
it all so what do you get when you take
a society of sentient creatures all
trying to grapple with their existence
as the property of underdeveloped humans
you get the most dystopian society that
you're gonna encounter in a movie this
year my comrades the long and short of
today's episode is this remember your
toys go back and visit that overcrowded
box of old stuffed animals the doodles
of Barbies crammed into your mother's
attic do it for the memories do it to
revisit a simpler time most importantly
of all do it to ingratiate yourself to
the toy who will one day be choosing how
to play with you let's hope that they
remember to play nice but hey that's
just a theory Oh film theory and while
we're on the subject of protecting
yourself from imminent threats around
your home let's talk about our sponsor
for today's episode Nord VPN well Nord
won't be able to protect you from your
old toys coming after you it can prevent
your phone aka your grown-up toy from
coming after you instead Nord is a
regular sponsor of film theory which
means that they're awesome and what they
do is awesome
what they do is to protect all your
internet II devices like your phone
tablet and computer from getting hacked
online using a VPN protects every byte
of data that comes into and leaves your
computer keeping all your email
passwords banking information and that
all-important HBO GO login information
away from anyone who shouldn't have
access to it which is pretty much
everyone but you yourself go into some
shady web sites or places where you
don't want other people knowing that
you're headed to VPN is gonna make sure
that that data stays private and with
the passage of laws like article 13 a
VPN like Nord is gonna be able to help
you get around all those pesky content
walls that are gonna be put up over the
next couple years Nord
is vast it has servers in 61 countries
with 24/7 customer support and
military-grade encryption that makes it
one of the most trusted online security
systems in the world and right now you
can get that world-class protection at
an amazing rate seventy-five percent off
a three-year plan all you have to do is
go to Nord VPN dot-com slash film theory
and then once you're checking out you
can use the code film theory again and
get yet another month completely free
that makes your subscription just $2.99
per month so you can browse and shop
online security across all of your
devices and then have that extra penny
left over to give a penny take a penny
at like the gas station anyway that is
Noren VPN dot-com / film theory or if
you know it's in the top line of the
description do it now and let Nord
protect the internet for you because
you've got like a thousand killer toys
in your attic that you got to worry
about instead if the Internet should be
the last thing on your mind so go ahead
get going and just be careful of any
sentient sporks that might be roaming
around your kitchen just saying